hey guys Greg Alba here got the red
couch back yeah I'm gonna watch the
trailer today I I think it's the
official trailer for cars three I think
it's the extended trailer I'm not sure
what trailer it is exactly but it was
sent over by many a subscriber so why
beat around the bush anymore cars is
easily the best franchise and all the
Pixar nothing beats it that's not
sarcasm
that is pure factual information this
[ __ ] trailer cars man
dark is serious
you
[Music]
breath
the copper you will never be the racer
you once were except it will my friend
McQueen retired I decide when I'm done
[Music]
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech racers you'll
never be as fast but you can be smarter
you need my help mr. McQueen okay on
board I'm coming for you storm
[Music]
you
[Music]
these trailers just keep getting better
and better now it's like a badass action
flick what's not playing I didn't watch
cars - I heard cars - is horrible I
didn't just watch it just because people
said was horrible I had just no no
interest in watching watching this
trailer I'm glad to see that the Cars
movie is going back to being a car
racing film I heard the last one was
like a spy film that seems to have a
very simple plot that might be packed
with more emotion than one might expect
I know the cars franchise is known to
not be like one of Pixar's best so I
feel like they're really trying to amp
us I'm more with even more personal
emotional involvement
it looks like Lightning McQueen he gets
torched at the beginning or whatever the
cars flipping all that [ __ ] this storm
car is the villain I'm interest I want
to see more of what makes him a villain
I could go for a cool Pixar villain so
far this is just like another teaser
trailer the way they're promoting this
film is very interesting because first
trailer did mean just the first half of
this trailer very dark and heavy second
trailer you know introducing some new
models reintroducing Lightning McQueen
but this is really about the races and I
really enjoy that it's really about the
car racing and it is harkening back more
to the first one where I remember Paul
Newman's car character but he had to
learn a lot of life lessons before he
could really go back into the racing
field again and here they have that line
that you may not be faster but you can
be smarter so he has to learn more yeah
that's going back to the first one of
Lightning McQueen having to learn
something about himself adapt new skills
and qualities that will allow him to win
the race and he's going to be getting
help from Cruz Ramirez the Latino
character though in those how many we
can use some good Latino characters in
these Cosmo movies so I'm interested to
see you know what is Jackson storms
character gonna be like will he be an
actual standout villain in some way
because you know you're promoting like
heaviness in these cars trailers a
little bit like this trailer is
definitely a lot lighter with the second
half of the trailer than the initial
teaser it's got that real action movie
vibe about it but you know you got army
hammer in the role as Jackson storm I
want to see like why'd you cast army
hammer while you get such a well-known
guy I don't like you in animated movies
get like a big big name for a voice role
and they don't really utilize this
person's talents or capabilities so I
want to see what Jackson storms gonna be
like I'm interested to see the journey
the Lightning McQueen can go on based
off the emotion they're packing in the
marketing system for this movie I'm
hoping it's more than just amping it up
but they are saying that we're gonna put
a lot more TLC into its characters and
whatnot to make this a much better film
in the last couple installments or you
know cars the franchises makes a lot of
money on merchandising so it could just
be that - alright guys what do you think
of the trailer you excited for this Cars
movie huh huh huh you can subscribe a
day if you like huh huh huh I know the
cameras coming this off of my sister she
drew this one it's cutting it off here
maybe just punch out a little bit me
okay so cuts it off that's ash from evil
dad tahrir to Ryan Gosling from Dr
American Psycho my sister drew all these
she's awesome
there's nothing you can follow her on I
just wanted to say I love you Megan